thank you for joining us America and the
Cole is in Atlanta
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Nicole
are you better than I deserve what's up
well I've been hiding under a rock for
all this time because I just recently
looked on the youtubes and I found you
yesterday last night so I'll give it a
shot and call you today well currently
I'm working full-time I'm a new
homeowner a person to home last year
prior to me purchasing my home I was
debt-free all of my credit cards was
paid off because I was living with my
parents at the time so I was saving
money hmm so holding fast forward the
credit card debt is back and I'm become
pastors well after I purchased my home I
just got a little carried away and I
wanted to buy new things for the house
because I it was a fixer-upper so I
wanted the new appliances someone is a
new family room set so how much how much
credit card debt do you have now
thirteen thousand three hundred and
twenty seven dollars okay and how much
do you owe on your car
um 25 thousand okay and what's your
household income right now it's just me
and it's thirty nine thousand dollars
okay and how much is your house payment
my house payment is seven hundred and
ninety seven dollars okay well the
credit cards exposed the stupidity of
the car the car is insanity in this
situation and your your house purchase
is reasonable so your hunt your home I
would keep the house I'd sell the car
and I'd take six extra jobs and get
these credit cards paid off and get you
a car you can pay cash for because if
you don't having car payments and you
wouldn't have any credit card payments
and if you don't have any car payments
or credit card payments you'd have a lot
of room and its budget wouldn't you yeah
and that sounds pretty dramatic I know I
just you know I just just just like that
I just sold your car but it is just a
stupid car and right now it owns you
when your car when you owe more than
half your annual in
come on your car you have too much tied
up in things that are going the wrong
way
because you're sitting there with about
a five hundred six hundred dollar car
payment aren't you 477 yeah pretty close
okay and to see if that was gone you
know you can clean the thirteen thousand
up real fast and when those two are gone
you can afford to save for an emergency
fund you can afford to save up and
purchase things for the home in cash or
purchase a trip or do investing or
whatever other things you want to do but
you've got no wiggle room right now
you're starving to death today right I'm
living day by day yeah yeah so what I
want to do is I'm gonna put you on a
budget you're brand new to all of this
and you don't have to go do what I said
today but you're gonna eventually work
to those decisions that I just gave you
you're gonna find your way back to them
after you get over thinking I'm crazy
okay because I have to my theory is is
to get rid of the credit card debt first
and in Chacoan student loans after our
tackle of student loans and tackle on
the mortgage with the loan for the house
okay what we teach folks to do is this
may be step one the first thing you're
gonna do and you're squeezed a thousand
dollars out of your life and out of your
budget and set it aside as a beginner
rainy day fund do you have any money and
savings at all yeah you need to get it
up to at least a thousand a little bit
of wiggle room in case some little thing
happens it's not gonna cover much but
it'll cover a little bit then the second
goal is to pay off all of your debt
except your home and that's maybe step
two and you do that by listing your
debts smallest to largest paying minimum
payments on everything but the little
one and you attack the little one in
your case that is going to be the credit
cards because they are your smallest two
debts aren't they they are but the the
thing is that I'm not bringing in enough
income - yeah yeah like I told you man
ago you got to get another job okay
you're gonna have to pick up part-time
job I don't know whether it's waiting
tables delivering pizzas uber I don't
know or whatever it is you do what do
you do for a living I'm a single
processor I work for an insurance
company okay is there anybody
let you do some of that work on the side
no okay alright then take some of those
skills or some other skills that you've
had in the past and let's just create
some temporary income I mean I don't
want you to I'll just make it up but as
an example you deliver pizzas five six
nights a week you make $1,500 a month
you had $15 a month to your budget we
start to clean this mess up pretty fast
right okay okay so we're gonna work the
baby steps step by step by step through
this first get current on everything and
then begin to knock off the little one
then the next little one then the next
little one it'll take a little while for
the snow ball to start rolling but every
time you pay one off you got more wiggle
room and you're gonna start to feel like
for the first time in several months
that you're winning because right now
you're distressed right and it doesn't
mean you're a bad person hey let me tell
you the call I've done stupid with zeros
on the end so I know what stupid looks
like and I know how I don't know how
about it makes you feel yeah you move
out of your house and all of a sudden
you get you a house you thought it was
all being smart and when you're 27 28
years old actually I'm 30 okay pretty
close yeah that's about where I thought
you'd be and you know you so you're
feeling like by now I should have my act
together so you got all the shame and
stuff that goes with this all that's
that's bogus cuz everybody does what
you've done the trick is to break the
cycle and never go back that's you know
shame is in the rearview mirror and we
put it in rear view mirror we call that
grace okay we've all done stupid I just
don't want to live there it's painful
right I want to get away from it one
drive away as fast as I can and so I'll
help you with this jump on to every
dollar and start your budget every
dollar calm is a free budgeting app for
your iPhone or your Android or your
desktop whatever you want to do or all
three I don't care it's all free takes
you about 10 minutes to build out your
budget and then you got to keep your
budget done every single month for that
matter every single week you got to stay
right on top of it all the time making
every dollar behave pick up some extra
income start looking for what you can
sell and then let's start talking about
getting this car sold and getting out of
there I'm gonna send you a copy of the
book that will give you the outline of
these baby steps and exactly how to do
them the book is called the total money
make over New York Times best-selling
book but on the bestseller list for over
a thousand weeks now so hold on and I'll
send you a copy that is my gift you walk
through that and if you get scared or
it's not working you call me back
anytime I'll help you anytime it's what
I'm here for
thanks for the call hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]